we got to talk about V ramaswami he said
a whole bunch of things on stage last
night at the GP debate he said January 6
looks like an inside job he's wrong
January 6 is definitively an inside job
because there's videos of police
officers opening the door Fanning people
in taking selfies with them and giving
them guided tours so if that that's not
an inside job I don't know what is but
he also said that great replacement
theory is not a conspiracy theory it's
Democrat policy and of course now van
Jones has said he's shaking hearing this
man who's going to live Trump by 50
years and this is the r of like Nazi
fascist whatever okay well how about I
play a clip of Van Jones saying that he
and and the woke left are asking white
people to give up on being a majority
and accept becoming a minority quite
literally echoing claims made by by
those who are discussing a great
replacement so we'll talk about that